you know it's crazy all the symptoms you
was having like yo lightheaded you can't
sleep you're hungry
what signs of like i used to have that
when i used to think my girl was
cheating on me oh really
i think that's called anxiety but yeah
sure
i didn't i didn't know you thought your
girl was cheating on you hell yeah
really i drove down i drove past
her current girl no no i don't know old
school yeah because she was bad
shawn yeah big sean her name was big
sean no no no
she she big sean like yeah yeah but i
drove past
how i
i've never heard that what the b stands
for uh big
malik big yeah well yeah
with three g's but big sean that's
literally his and he's he's a
small dude yeah he is small by two by
the way
i saw him in real life five two five
you could take him hell yeah oh yeah you
can beat him up oh
my god yeah he's tiny but yeah great
great rapper well that's great i mean he
won't say that now
you know he's a good musician not now
after what happened you think he's going
to say he's a great rapper that boy's
stacking
he's in his feelings i'm not in my
feelings i'm not drake
oh no okay you see are you y'all
it's crazy though that this nickname big
sean can't just him have a giant dick
that sucks your girl is cheating on you
with him though man that's a tough one
though
how'd you figure it out i drove past her
car like she told me she was uh like at
home
i drove past her like crib her apartment
and there was a gate and i ain't see her
car and it's like three o'clock in the
morning if you have to do that it's
already over well i don't know i knew i
was like i'm about to crash
and it was early in the morning now it
was late at night 3 a.m
okay that's it that's early in the
morning but um yeah
so you drove by there and were you like
where are you called her phone she ain't
saying
she didn't say like call the phone you
went straight to voicemail i was like i
hope it's dead
it wasn't dead it was not dead it wasn't
dead but dialed me back
down me back all i heard was rap lyrics
i got up
oh man i left i was in the car
i just parked the car just started
walking with the hazard lights i don't
[ __ ] him with
you bro i deleted it oh i went to his
playlist i deleted all his music
it's not his ass ass ass ass i mean
not his fault though you know who
thought is it it's hers yeah you're
right because
he doesn't know bruh he doesn't know now
i got a queen that like really like when
she text me good night she really go to
sleep
ooh level up level up come on
you don't think of it when chess good
night she's really going good night
good night you don't think about when
women take you good night what they
doing this is the same one that helped
fix your tire
yes that's that's right or die yeah come
on she saw this episode she was laughing
that's how she was cool with oh my uncle
loves you about oh really
yeah with the guy who's like you two
near me not to hear me he too near me
not to hear me he called he called me
bro what was he saying though that was
[ __ ] he was like you two near me not
to be around me i was like
what the hell i really wiped it out you
really wind it up
come on now when i get off stage at the
lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this is from
a bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son